a fresh wave of strikes is beginning as
the year of industrial action continues
across the country Royal Mail workers
University lecturers sixth form staff
are taking part in walkouts today joined
Now by Simon Thompson Chief exec at the
Royal Mail
um hello to Mr Thompson thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
when are you going to get these posties
back to work
well the first thing I would say is I
just want to offer a huge apology to our
customers both our retail customers that
trust us to deliver things to the door
and also our customers that receive
things at the door and the other thing I
would just like to make really really
clear is that we are doing absolutely
everything we can
to make sure that we protect Christmas
whilst the CW leadership are doing
everything they can to destroy Christmas
in terms of our posties we've offered
them a nine percent uh pay increase
that's a cost of 400 million pounds for
us as a business and that's 400 million
pounds when we're losing 1.2 million
pounds a day we really do feel that that
is fair and the other thing as well I
would add is that we've been accused by
the CW of want to be a gig economy
business and this again is totally not
true you know we have 97 permanent
employment we pay 18 to 14 more than the
industry norm and I even offered them
the opportunity of having a campaign
together on improving the standards in
the industry and they turned me down on
that I also offered them the opportunity
of a profit sharesky and they also
turned me down on that and on my way in
this morning I was listening to the
radio and I heard one of our customers
biscateers who were very very clear in
their asks which is they want us to give
us seven day delivery service for
Parcels they want us to be able to
deliver those Parcels overnight and they
were also very very clear that this
disruption of to Christmas is really not
good for their customers and is not good
for their business
um you listed some of the things that
the union has been accusing you of trust
me when I tell you that the leader of
the Union was on the program last week
accusing you more of that said than that
saying that his members were being
intimidated by
um the Royal Mail in order to do things
they didn't want to do
do you know I'm actually pleased that
you raised that point because on strike
action days we've seen some
extraordinary behaviors we've had
allegations of racism we've had
allegations of sexism we've had people
threatened with violence we've had
people actually suffering actual
violence it's an extraordinary situation
and it's not something that we will ever
tolerate we have some cases that are
currently going through our processes
and we will be taking action as is
required
okay so you've been accused of sexism
and racism
um what would you say are you
no as I said that we have had some
allegations and we take these things
very very seriously and we make sure
that if there's anybody that is not
behaving correctly regardless of who
they are in the organization I would add
that they are dealt with in the most
Swift and best way possible okay thank
you for clarifying that also um Mr Ward
the union leader went on to say he
challenged you actually on my program
last week to say
come and sit down and meet with him at
any stage to try to get this resolved
we have been talking for seven months to
try and get this situation resolve
around change and for the first six
months the union did not engage in those
discussions at all I then offered them
the opportunity of joining me with acass
and I have to say that did eventually
happen and a big thank you to the team
of acas I thought they were professional
and dedicated to try and help us resolve
this situation it took the CWU nearly a
month to take me up on that offer we
then spent three weeks in intensive
talks including weekends which I also
participated in and at the end of that
they rejected our change agenda
completely out of hand
um Mr Ward said that he would come on
this program at any time to debate with
you will you come on and debate with him
on the program
I think that what we need to be spending
our time on that's a yes Mr Thompson
he's prepared to come on the program you
say you want to get this sorted out can
you come on the program and discuss it
with him
I think what we need to be dedicating
our time on here is executing the agenda
for change that we need so we can
compete and win in the market we've
given our final offer it is not
something that is negotiable but I'm
more than happy to meet Mr Ward to
discuss our final offer I think that
what the CWU are doing is they are
distracting away from the actual core of
the issue here the core of the issue
here is that we used to be a letters
business we are now a Parcels business
we spent 900 million pounds on
investments so we can compete and win in
the market and as for the business plan
here is the business plan that the CWU
actually offered me on one piece of
paper it is not costed it has no
timelines I question whether this is
actually at all credible okay well Mr
Ward's coming on the program tomorrow
um you are very welcome to come on and
join in if not then you know you're
giving him a free reign that's up to you
let me ask you briefly Before I Let You
Go I can't post is have the England flag
on their vans
well what I would say is that we support
everyone and every team and we're making
sure that our team can have time to
watch the games as they wish and that's
for absolutely every team I think in
terms of flags on Vans I'm afraid it's a
safety issue and a safety question and
so therefore we have to make sure we
keep people safe but we definitely wish
every team well and any of our policies
that would like to watch those games we
hope that they definitely enjoy them
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for joining us much
appreciated maybe I'll see you tomorrow
thank you very much